you are looking at voters casting their
ballots in Miami this morning as polls
are opening across the country let's go
back to Tony in Florida where Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis is trying to win a
second term and is leading in the polls
Tony what's the latest
hey Nate well you know I love talking to
people one of my favorite things to do
almost every story I do involves a
conversation with somebody out there in
America and I've been talking to voters
here in Florida there's a lot of
enthusiasm for Ron DeSantis as you point
out but I would also point out that
polls are just guesses they're educated
guesses but they're only guesses and
I've been talking to people campaign
volunteers I've been talking to people
at rallies some of the most passionate
voters that there are in this country
went to a barber shop went to a
Fairground a racetrack I gotta say all
of it is really enough to get you Misty
about our American experiment people
really do care in this country and here
are the top issues that people are
talking about what's on voters Minds
according to our CBS News polling those
issues include the economy it includes
inflation crime election issue election
issues and here's what's at stake really
the next two years of Joe Biden's
presidency whether he will have a
Congress that will work with him to help
Advance his agenda or a Congress that
will block it from moving forward